in one two three
happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you i want her fake
eyelashes to catch on fire
happy birthday dear esther
there's a cupcake that matches your
sweatshirt happy birthday
to you we made it look like your skid
marks in your diapey
it's for me me oh
three candles for this
the three women who sit before me
there's three of us
uh oh that's not oh she's weak she has
asthma
you guys trying to kill me oh look she's
upset look she's mad at her cupcake
throw it like a little kid when they cry
you guys this was so nice thank you so
much happy birthday sweet little angel
boy
oh my gosh you guys welcome to bloodbath
this is a very
very special episode because our sweet
little baby slug is now a woman
we're introducing her into society she
is ready for
pregnancy this is our conception
what they do when you're a debutant
they're like here a debutant what's
going on with your pronunciations of
things today why do you debut time
it's not a diaper
excuse me the refugee is very refugee
today how do you say it please correct
me i feel like i'm the ref of your
refugee
you said diaper i know but how you say
debutant
debutant oh god you can say i don't care
i like
i like the way you pronounce things you
don't even want to hear how how
we call it the boo we don't call it
debut debut
who says dabu gabby here's another
filipino it's the boo right
that's cute when you turn 18 esther you
you you have a dabu
and it's a kind of like a cotillion and
you dance with 18 men
and 18 of 18 men 18 men
you pick your 18 crushes and you dance
with them
and then is one like your cousin because
your mom's like come on just put your
cousin in there yeah because there's
never 18 guys
nobody's ever picked him for his
is anyone else bleeding today i am just
ending my blood
like i'm at the point where i'm not
wearing underwear or a tampon but
there's still
it's a [ __ ] one
wait it's a fudgies that's what you are
that's day seven
eight and nine is the fudgies what i
don't have that
liar fudgies is duty no fudgies
is
[Laughter]
that you do please i'm begging
please i'm salvating you guys dude can't
happen
the jewish girl slobbering surprise
surprise it's called a fistula
when you're when your stuff crosses over
into another part of your body so you
have doo doo in your
um not doo doo hole
speaking of fistulas and slushies
7-eleven is still not serving slurpees
esther and i used to do a our exercise
was to walk to get slurpees
and we had to walk slow i didn't even
realize the reason i don't believe that
esther is asthma is she has never
used as an excuse to slow down before
what do you because i've never noticed
i love a fast walk i walk fast is that
what not what you were going to say
that's your fast oh no well your legs
are little so even a fast walk is
regular
yes i have to keep up with the regular
people and that booty just boo
booing back and forth the duty getting
passed from one side of the cheek to the
other side of the cheek
you can hear the crunching of her diaper
oh my god get her out of here
get her out of here my birthday present
to her is to talk about her doodoo hole
we should probably explain our outfits i
don't think you need to
i've gotten very used to your bagel head
um this is in honor of my favorite bagel
eater
my my skokie queen i know you love
bagels
in fact i was gonna bring you bagels
today but george because he lives next
to courage big
it's it's too hard to get it it's too
hard it would pre-order yeah it wouldn't
have been nice and fresh by the time i
got here but this is
this is an honor of your love for bagels
is self-explanatory it's
gorgeous that's an amazing jeans i
didn't have those cool little gel
nikes that but i i do have these are
these my little esters
they are look the shoes i wear almost
every day are ugly
but they are comfortable and that's what
counts just like me
um there's also one more element that we
haven't introduced to this
dress like yesterday and that is um
bring it out george
adult diapers oh
sorry adult diapers i did it one day
and nobody can let it go in the front
what brand did we get
i don't know i like esther we should do
unboxings of different
the amazon brand is very flattering on
flattering
i think all of them are pretty
flattering these days well i take that
back these don't look very and annie i
like your
hot for my name sweatshirt my stand up
special merch which is now streaming on
paramount plus
i have to i have no underwear on because
i was going to wear this but
i don't know why i thought that was a
good idea now okay so i did
get some adult diapers last summer i
thought it would be very convenient for
the pandemic
because you look you're you're going to
be out you might not want to use a
public restroom you might have an
emergency so you might want to go
in your diaper now it's harder to go
in a diaper than you think because she
didn't leave her house though i mean
it's like
let's be real you didn't you were like
how do i stay more on my couch you
are it's you're so well trained
to not pee in a diaper anymore if you
tried you wouldn't be able to i'm gonna
do it i could do it right now i gotta go
i have to change i have to put it inside
annie do you wanna pee together yeah
let's go pee together without esther oh
my god that's the greatest birthday
present fomo
and for your birthday you get fomo you
don't think that annie and i can pee in
this diaper i
am going to piss in this dog i don't
think you can hang on what about my
[ __ ] beer
oh my bagel hold my bagel i'm going to
show you more than just me little one
hold my ketamine i'll be right back hold
my bagel
you look hot i told you they're
flattering
oh no i didn't know this is what
kalila's body looked like i'm upset
i'm upset my my diaper is locked and
loaded
my diaper okay now let's see the big
talkers
if they can pee we have the whole
episode to do it
us getting ready should be thrown into
an only fans account yeah you can't just
see our hairy legs for free
you can't see ourselves certainly not
what is the deal with only fans
like i see people using it in non-sexy
ways these days
well that would be our only option can i
just pause for a second
esther is obviously the one that's most
likely to have subscribed to several
only fans
she is just wanking off to so many
[ __ ]
full full-figured women okay i have
subscribed to a couple
of you did yes i have and then she's
like but what is it
this is esther to a t she's the
creepiest one and she plays the most
innocent
and for her birthday we'll pretend madam
yes little one
we it's scary to see vaginas spread
here's the thing a lot of only fans are
not showing at all
it's suggestive yeah you can do whatever
you want yeah you can do a cooking show
on there if you wanted to that's what
they well you have to pop the eggs with
your puss
we can throw annie's pixelated foot
picks in there at least less pixelated
than her usual
yeah you see a toe hair is this a real
conversation about a blood bath only
fans
i think that it's a a wonderful
idea i do too it's not going to be your
average only fans
like esther said it's going to be um us
changing into adulthood well sometimes
people see us and they're like they say
they're fat old [ __ ] but
are they and we want to prove to you for
twenty dollars a month
that we yes we are fat old wars leave
out that price we don't want people to
know the price until they click
and it's too late oh i have an idea
forty dollars
bleep her i can hundred dollars sleep
her
bleep the old home five hundred dollars
birthday
come on look at her car i'm i'm willing
to throw pictures of my day seven eight
and nine fudgies on there
oh my god i did take a picture of my
underwear today and i almost texted it
to you guys why didn't you
i should have she knew i already had
headaches what if that was the care of
my headache i just had to see your skid
marks
it's not skid marks it's it's officially
it's ah but it was skidded around
i bled in my on my couch what would we
do on our only fans would you would one
of you guys shave the other one's
butthole
yeah gladly i know annie and i have been
wanting to do that for years
dying to get in that [ __ ]
i'm looking at that donut like i want to
[ __ ] get that donut too
esther's just going sorry i was just
thinking like a five minute bonus
episode
is gonna be like this like oh my god in
the corner
just annie i don't know
oh my god the cameras are off she's
fisting herself oh please
stop you can't piss yourself you
probably are such a dirty little
you do have literally that's the thing
you're definitely the dirtiest [ __ ] in
this group oh
stop it you definitely are no it's we
know it's kalila
the dirtiest luck is a refugee she has a
lot to prove
you guys i've had to work so hard in my
life to be recognized okay
brown people don't have it as easy we do
not have an equal playing field
therefore i've had to suck
way more dicks to get to where i am
that's true just to get out of rehab she
had to blow her
out of here i kind of did
she gummed her way out of rehab i never
got to go to rehab but not yet
nobody cared about you enough i did try
to go to rehab once i called i crashed
my scooter i was in
santa fe and i was this story is
actually
wicked this is one of my wickedest
stories so i was uh
living in santa fe i was like 25 it was
right before i quit drinking
i was 25. i got completely drunk it was
my friend's 30th birthday so
my joke was it's your 30th birthday buy
me a drink so i kept making him buy me
shots of tequila so i was like
hammered and i was and he had dreadlocks
he was so gross but i was like i'm gonna
suck your dick for your birthday
this is such a ratchet story i was like
[ __ ] blow you for your birthday i'm
getting so drunk
right neither of us lived anywhere
that's my friend albert wait
so i had to go to my friend daniel i've
always been like sleeping on my friend's
couch as my whole life what does it mean
to not live anywhere it's like
no you know what i did actually i did
live at my friend david's house but
david's like was a real person with a
real job so i couldn't like
bring people home to blow but so okay so
it's my friend's birthday 30th birthday
i'm like i'm gonna blow you at daniel's
house so
i had this motor scooter race to ride
around town and i would beep it or go
like beep beep hotty
and just like cruise off and one time i
beeped at a um it's like a mobile
[ __ ]
it was so like yeah i'm trying to blow
them while i'm on my scooter
back and speed up it's like in la you
lived in a car but back there you lived
in your scooter inside my scooter
you could pot you pop the seat up you
can't
but so i would like drive by people and
uh one time i drove by i was like day
drinking and there was a chain gang like
picking up trash
they were in their like orange jumpsuits
and i like drove by them and i like
flash and i was like what are you in for
and um then my scooter stalled and i had
to walk my i had to put my shirt back
down and walk my scooter by them it was
so embarrassing
i was like i hope not rape and then
um so then and by the way i thought i
made that
these stories are so crazy and i was
always so drunk that i'm always like did
i make the story up and then this guy
when i did chelsea lately
sent me an email this random dude that i
met drunk at a bar and he goes hey
i just want to let you know i met you
five years ago
in santa fe at a bar and you said you
were wasted and you said you were moving
to new york to become a comedian he's
like and you [ __ ] did it i just saw i
just saw you on tv
and he's like here's a picture if you
don't remember me here's a picture you
signed my shirt
i said i wanted your autograph so i
signed a shirt and i said today i
flashed a chain gang and my scooter
broke
and he said i said wrote that on his
skirt on a shirt and i was like oh my
god that didn't
happen you still had dreams no matter
how drunk you were yeah i was like i'm
going to be a comedian
your ambitions were beyond just getting
my teeth knocked out yeah
gum dicks
so anyway so it's my friend's birthday
and i'm like i'm gonna blow you at
daniel's house and he's like okay
we're so drunk we're leaving the cowgirl
this restaurant i was working at
and uh what did you do there i was a i
was a bartender and waitress that's why
i used to wait on sam shepard the
playwright
wow that's another good story sam
shepard used to come in
and i would make him uh what i can't
remember what it's called but i would
make him these margaritas with gold
tequila
hot girl stories are just different yeah
well he never hit i was always like why
is sam shepard not hitting on me and
so we were sitting i was hanging out i
got off work one day and we were sitting
at the bar
we were drinking and i was like 23 but i
was like i just thought i'd
be have a different life by this age you
know i thought i'd be living an
extraordinary life and he's like
but you are he's like you're gay right
if i was a lesbian
and then that would be like my
extraordinary i was like what he's like
you're gay my best friend was a legend
she did finger me a couple times
but um he was like i thought you were
gay and i was like no
and then i was going to make shirts that
said sam shepard thinks i'm gay
and uh throw it on our throw it on our
emergency shepherd thinks i'm gay
we have to give his estate 10 because
he's dead now but then i told him i was
like i want to be a comedian i want to
do
like i like doing improv and stuff he's
like improv so scary we had this whole
conversation about it
and then i was like i really want to be
a comedian and then uh like three years
later i had moved to
to new york and i was working as a
waitress and i was doing open mics and
doing stand-up
and sam shepard walked by as i was
setting up the patio seats
and he walked by with like his family
and i was like oh my god i was like sam
it's me andy from santa fe i moved to
new york i'm doing stand-up i did it and
he was like
uh did this used to be a jazz club
[Laughter]
okay touche
but anyway that happened to me very
recently oh no i went to like this food
tasting thing of a chef who i thought
knew who i was because we'd hunt we had
these great dinners together
and so i dragged gabby's brother gilbert
to this one
so-and-so's like pop-up thing let's go
he's gonna treat us so well
because like we've we've seen him so
many times right
and then when we got there and gilbert
was so excited because gilbert's a big
foodie he was like oh my god you have
that connection that's so cool let's go
there this
big foodie overweight
we got there he looked at me he just
kept walking and i was like chef
chef chef it's me and i had to name drop
three different people's names
for him to be like oh yeah i think i
remember and poor gilbert was
so sad like i just saw his heart like
breaking in his chest because he was
like we're not gonna be
given the good stuff the secret menu
i'll tell you guys later it really did
break my heart but eventually
down the road he re he he now follows me
on instagram
he's like oh you're the crazy girl that
swims chef at me
i was like chef chef it's me i know
she's talking about
i really want to get to the history of
the diaper
i'm never going to say that word again
because annie is giving me [ __ ] side
eyes i'm trying to help you
diaper she's the only one that
pronounces the a and diaper i just want
to add though that i know how you guys
feel like i always try to be the first
first person to say hi
you know like i like wave hi to someone
and when you are that person
literally 50 of the time the person does
not see you or they pretend not to see
you so i have so many instances of
waving hi
your hands so little they can't see it
they don't and it's so it hurts
it hurts it's a mistake it's a mistake
to come in that thirsty or that hot
i can't just think or something i name
dropped you at the doctor's office and i
thought
it was the other nurse that knew you
yeah and i said your name so many times
i thought i was going to get special
treatment we were the same doctor
but it was a different it was like a new
nurse i pulled a picture up of you
yeah if it was marnie martin it wasn't
marnie's oh yeah
but see annie and i are eskimo sisters
because
we see the same um doctor now she's
now seeing my family doctor and she got
a pap smear two weeks after i got a pap
smear
first day i went in they're like do you
want a pap smear and i was like
uh [ __ ] yeah yeah sure
and then he came in and he's this cute
little asian man he came in and he was
like
he's like oh we got you down for but
he's like let's talk a little first i
was like thank you
i didn't want to go right in
oh i'm glad you shaved i had used the
the razor we should have him on the show
and compare
and have him break down the differences
between your guys our vaginal walls
yeah who has a stronger taint he's
always really careful he's like looks
good
get out of here again he's nice he
understands and they need to have a
woman in there with him
yeah he always has two for me there's
always like two women in there what to
pry it open dude she's so tight
one each one on each side tight like gut
me like a pig
esther back to the the diaper history i
told you guys
i i thought i was making a smart move
i told i was really proud of myself i
told my fiance and he was
disgusted he was angry he was like
what's wrong with you this isn't funny
i'm like i i really think this is smart
in the pandemic to like have
it's so weird that dave is so not a fan
of yours
he doesn't like anything about you i
know i always try to tell them that him
that he's like no that's not true
but yeah i i wasn't able to pee in the
diaper though it wasn't it's too hard to
like
push pee out while you're sitting it's
hard to tell it's like
[ __ ] yourself when you're pushing had
you watched um
that um had you heard the news story
about that one
astronaut who lady who sat in her diaper
for what was it like 48 hours
is that your your your queen that what
is like when i grow up i want to be an
astronaut not to go to space but i can
go can we clarify what the story is
because
in my mind it's like she drove to see a
lover she was she was a jilted lover
yeah and i think that she had a cheating
spouse so she drove like three states
across did not stop once
strapped up put on a diaper and then
she wanted to kill him i think she
kidnapped him she did she couldn't have
her maddie
well she had stuff to kidnap him she had
like duct tape and stuff and she was a
[ __ ] astronaut she was a brilliant
mind of our time
wow women can be astronauts too i also
had road trips in mind
when i started researching the diapers i
was like oh if i do
cause the pandemic maybe i'm gonna drive
to chicago
such a brilliant that's actually like
the only way to justify these diapers
see and you're not into just um free
[ __ ] like just finding digging a
hole and pulling
thinking and then covering it up because
that's just more hygienic and you don't
get baby diaper rash
are you from like a place where they use
one hand wait i don't have potable water
where i'm from guys i'm actually
insulted that you're assuming i would
poo
in the diaper the diaper is for pee oh
what if there's a trick
for that it's for pee because you have
to pee all the time and yeah
wait till you see this diaper diaper
that i'm if you ever
think that as a healthy adult that you
could
[ __ ] in a diaper and then sit in it oh i
don't know i don't know you in that way
sir i just had these assumptions it
would leak into your
special areas and then it would be what
is it called what did you say it's
called when things get mixed
oh fistula fistula i thought if whatever
i don't we don't need to explain this
you guys i have so much body pain
from the way i sit and just you know
living
as a life as an esther if i didn't have
the thera gun i don't know what i would
do
oh my god i use it to bang out my lower
back i bang out my hips my
what can i bang your hips out no my
theragun
and this new theragun that we have the
gen 4
it has this soft attachment so it's
literally like
it's like a hard hard pressure but with
a soft foamy attachment it feels so good
it's better than a massage
you guys you guys know i'm an ex-athlete
a has-been
therefore i have a lot of uh cricks and
pains
this is how you say it cricks i i call
my cricks and pains esters
i have a lot of cricks and pains so when
i work out these days
um i absolutely need the theragun it is
my go-to
to um it cuts my recovery in half and
um i just overall feel more sprite and
ready for the next workout
theragun is the handheld percussive
therapy device that releases your
deepest muscle tension using a
scientifically calibrated combo of depth
speed and power and it's as quiet as an
electric toothbrush
the gen 4 theragon doesn't just feel
good it gets to the source of the pain
by releasing tension
using theracon theragun's signature
percussive therapy which goes
60 deeper than vibration alone whether
you want to treat your muscle tension
from working out like kalyla
or an injury probably like annie or just
the stress of everyday life
like me there's no substitute for the
theragun
gen 4. try theragun for 30 days starting
at only 199
that's actually a steal it's
unbelievable that price is for the mini
which i have as well
go to theragan.com bloodbath right now
and get your gen
4 theragun today that's theragun.com
bloodbath theragun.com bloodbath
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
say it with us
blue shoes making waves and bringing
more confidence to the bedroom by
offering chewable tablets
that can help men get stronger and
longer lasting directions
esther how long does your boner last
annie
tell them bluechu is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
and at a fraction of a cost
bluetooth tablets help men achieve
harder stronger erections
to combat all forms of erectile
dysfunction which happens to the best of
us which happens to everybody no shame
in the cd
is an online prescription service so
there's no visits to the doctor's office
there's no awkward conversations and no
waiting in line
they don't tell you to cough and it
shifts right to your door in a discreet
package like most things that annie
orders the process is simple
sign up at bluechew.com consult with one
of the licensed medical providers and
once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part it's all done online
blue chews licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength for your
prescription
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and they prepare and ship the wreck so
it's cheaper than a pharmacy
you guys if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try blue chew
free when you use promo code bathgirls
at checkout just pay five dollars for
shipping that's bluechew.com promo code
bathgirls
to receive your first month free and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast yeah
you chew so we can swallow
can we give her some presents yeah i
think we should i have a very special
present for her as well okay wait i got
esther some presents then we got her an
epic present
um i i just found out that these exist
and it
got sent to me in the most ratchet
like perfect like it just came like this
it doesn't look like much but it is a
lot esther
the wind is on my side thank you
what is this is it like can you believe
they just sent it like that i'm like
there's a box
it's called underwear for two
you're co-dependent i knew you would
like this oh
my god who's getting in with me i wish
there's another
a third one oh my god should we save it
for when we're all
vaccinated yeah well here i have another
um i'm making dave do this with me this
is for our only fans
yes this is the content you will be you
know you know what it is
my gift is you guys taking pictures in
this for me and i'm the photographer
no you're in in between us she's the
photographer on all fours fingering
herself
she's doing a reach around on herself oh
stop it oh she's like stop
i have the last uh um what i think is a
very important gift george if you can
pass this over to esther
oh it's a maxi pad there's an l after
that
double d in the first line is this a
special coupon like you're gonna get
double d that's like a free massage from
kalila
esther uh kalaila and are gonna put
strap-ons on a
rotisserie oh my god two ester from coco
this coupon is good for
one adult swaddle and 10 minute cradle
expires never
[Laughter]
oh my god wait so tell me what this will
be like
okay so have you ever seen a baby being
swaddled yes i have
i put you in a blanket and i wrap you
really tight and i hold you for 10
minutes
oh my god i'm getting my i'm not i
happened to ask her but she was duct
taped her mouth shut
like duct taped her i'm literally
getting tingles at the thought of my
swaddle
and my cradle and annie gets to beat you
with a bat while you're swallowed
i get to haze you like you're joining my
frat
wait i have something else for you wow i
should have done i should have added
that i'll throw you in the air like a
baby a couple times
okay i'm gonna wait when i was little
we'd play row row where
they would i would be they'd put me in a
blanket and then they would like swing
the blanket
and then it was really sad because when
i wanted to go know when i wanted to
keep doing it and i was too old
and for years i would beg and beg i
think we can i like your actually
stopped let's do that for the only fans
that's railroad
i thought it was gonna be with fish eggs
on you
but you guys isn't row row like a form
of like torture to kill someone
through like anally [ __ ] them what
i've never heard is wrong with you
why would you even say that about my
childhood
i don't know what you're doing also
these gifts are so nice like i really
hope this show gets canceled by the time
it's your guys's birthday wait i have
another really important one for you
because i gave you the one mask and
you've been wearing it for 10 years 10
weeks straight i got you a new one oh i
i bought some
oh no you got rejected
hey you just [ __ ] ruined that mask in
the pool
the turtles annie the turtles good i
hope the turtle's dying
i'm team straw turtles are disgusting
she just ruined a mask
good i'm gonna ruin your [ __ ] makeup
too [ __ ] put the mask on now [ __ ]
i was trying to be nice and bomber masks
i was trying to save you the mask
those are expensive they are expensive
but i don't give a [ __ ] i'm made of
money
i'll dry it out i'll reuse them
[Music]
by the way i'm on so much ketamine
because my classroom this is the
funniest [ __ ]
you guys are laughing but you don't
understand how comfortable these are
okay they're not they're more
comfortable than regular chairs
look at maury and this is imagination if
she's not locked in and she rolls
backward into that
cliff behind her and then actually needs
one
[Laughter]
that will be the greatest gift look at
the queen you guys
don't understand look i when i had to be
rolled in a wheelchair for a brief few
weeks
i tried all the wheelchairs and there
was one guy she broke her
smallest baby toe
she broke her baby toe oh oh and my
memories of being in japan are coming
back past the ramen
oh i feel she's like i have to be fed
and like you're like wrong your arms
oh i love it's so comfortable my back
and my butt thank you so much
i'm so happy they feel loved do you now
know that how much we care about you
we understand you know because it's kind
of more to make fun of me
[Laughter]
yours is your favorite thing
wow thank you so much this has been the
specialist birthday ever
my birthday was about two months ago
we have to keep pushing the birthday
episode
oh my goodness i couldn't be happier
than esther being in a wheelchair
like a happy chance have you ever seen
her smile so bright will someone push me
to my car
that's a steep hill i'll push him
not annie esther
before we started annie was saying how
my teeth were so white and you were like
you guys i don't want to
have this conversation because why
i a couple years ago before the pandemic
realized that i have a dead tooth
how did you realize it a doctor told me
and how does a tooth die
i don't know how it dies but was it from
sweets probably
she likes sweets i actually don't know
how it died but it just was really
sensitive to hot and too cold
and it started to turn gray maybe you're
dead those are the symptoms of being
dead
it's a very sensitive time well i
remember when the dentist was like it
has passed
and i was like thank you for using that
terminology like it helps
it helps it go down smoother but then i
was supposed to get a root canal but
then i never did because of the pandemic
so i don't know it's probably like up in
my brain wrought
is it a front tooth oh yeah it's near
the center
oh okay so i can't whiten my teeth
because i haven't noticed this
it's too sensitive it's very specific
lighting where you can see that it's
gray
like you either can't see it or you can
really tell i like to say that you don't
have a dead tooth you just have tie-dyed
teeth
thank you and that's marketing yes and
that's a brand manager
sleepover by esther the tooth edition
it's like some people get gold teeth
maybe i'll do a gray tie-dye and it'll
be called the dead tube
to celebrate the year anniversary since
my tooth has passed
my best friend um she had
a similar thing where she had i don't
know if it was a dead tooth but her
her front tooth like kind of just [ __ ]
off in the middle of a date of a first
date it [ __ ] off
it [ __ ] off like it actually left her
mouth i left the baby it took her
it went to i had a smoke break it
seceded it seceded from its
original country and um
and then she she was like oh excuse me
like i gotta go
um she kind of was able to cover it up
at first and then she called us from the
bathroom she's like
my tooth fell off in the middle of the
date what should i do should i go back
in there
and she went back in there and she
finished the date without a tooth she
just explained it as it she's like i
don't know what happened
if she didn't even explain it okay
you're
the closest thing i know to a doctor how
does the tooth just fall off say that in
a wheelchair so cocky look how cocky
she's sitting in a wheelchair
this is the funniest thing i've ever
seen
i should have brought you a tiara i
think she crunched on an egg roll too
hard and it was already a compromise
juice compromise too that is like an
ester move
to crunch too hard on us oh
look at the princess my queen
you are so cute as dirty little munchkin
head thank you [ __ ] well r.i.p
your tooth yeah no i mean you know the
body is still
with us but the spirit is gone the soul
the life you're carrying around a corpse
tooth
we should get a little um a little baby
casket for your
little like mini casket for your tooth
well it'll stay there it'll just
when they root canal they keep it there
i think so you can get a veneer you
could just take it down to a nub and
yeah
the mirrors are so great they're bad i
don't know why everyone's doing how
could you
get rid of your own teeth your own
they're yours you were born with them
your parents gave you those teeth you're
going to grind them down some people
aren't born with
superstar teeth like you annie some of
us have you know
calcium deficiencies because we're
refugees
you know i have some calcium deposits
why can't they make it work with what
it just seems like a shame that they
have to start anew and take away
everything you have to give you veneers
like
that's but people will just blindly go
about that because we're so vain
and as long as it makes us look better
especially in la i don't know if it's
bled out into the rest of the world but
i think it has it's an epidemic i think
even with um boys from the uk
because i watch island and their teeth
are always and they go on first
they go to thailand yes they pay like a
half the price they
normally would bad they all have bad
hair they have bad hair plugs and bad
teeth and they're so
obvious they're so they're a type of
weight that doesn't exist
half price teeth in thailand yeah yep
esther's got to break another toe she
get pushed pushed around another asian
country
can we go back to i feel like there was
some kind of
i feel like your story wasn't over my
story was not over
with sam it will never be over it was
there was about 20 stories in one
the ketamine really brings it out back
so okay so
it's my friend's birthday i'm like i'm
gonna blow you at daniel's house
oh yeah we didn't even get to the blow
down i gotta get to daniel's house so
everyone assumed that i was gonna be
like riding with someone because i was
so drunk but i
not me i hop on my scooter and
everyone's like no you can't drive
everyone's on the patio of this bar like
no don't drive and i was like [ __ ] you
pull my tits out like scoot off like and
then like turn a corner and
peel out and crash i had like nine
stitches on my chin
i busted my chin open i had cuts over my
nose the side of my head um
your chin was open my chin was
completely open my i was wearing a dress
and cowboy boots like a little mini
dress
and it was there was blood when i woke
up at my friend's house there was blood
i went back to my friend david's house i
was living in
blood like look someone had slipped my
throat david or daniel's house
dave daniel was where i was going to go
give the beage david was where i lived
that i couldn't bring it was he was a
real person so
i i go home i go back to the
someone picks me up i crash someone
picks me up all i remember in the
morning is that someone had that
that didn't usually like me had found me
and took me back to david's
and that i had called everyone in my
immediate family and told them i needed
to go to rehab
so then i was like [ __ ] i have to like
get out of this rehab [ __ ] so i like
i called david he was at his
girlfriend's house i was like david i
[ __ ] myself up like i need you to take
me to the hospital so he comes home
and then i call everyone in my meet
family i'm like hey like about that
whole rehab thing like i was in a
blackout
disregard and my older brother goes you
said you'd say that
so drunk me like ratted on sober me and
was like
don't let me get out of this but then my
parents were like you don't need rehab
for
drinking you need rehab for life because
they wanted me to go back to landmark i
was like
no i need to go to rehab but i didn't
want to go to rehab so i was like i just
i [ __ ] up but i'm gonna go to the
hospital so i got nine stitches in my
chin
my friend julian called me and was like
are you okay i was like how did you know
and he's like my boss picked you up so
my friend julian had worked at this
bar at a at a really nice hotel so i
would get hammered there all the time
for free
and his boss hated me because i was just
some like drunk [ __ ] like flashing all
these like
customers so she was the one that didn't
like me but came
but saw me on the street and then like
take me back to my friend
yeah she was nice excited when you
flashed them or were they just like
but that's why i think i was always okay
with flashing because like it's not no
one has a big reaction
pretty small um yeah everyone was always
like
like it doesn't change anyone's day like
it might inspire them to like get a
pepperoni pizza
i flash an audience once i tell this on
stage i flash an audience once and
literally like nothing happened and i
like turned to the other side of the and
i was like i just showed them my tits
and everyone
laughs so hard adam calls it flash gate
because nobody believes i flashed the
other side because there was no
like literally no one like had any
movement
neutral yeah they just like looked
had no no reaction at all but um
so anyway so i always think about that
time when i went to the
got my stitches and everything that it
saved me because those stitches healed
but the [ __ ]
herpes i would have gotten from my
friend why you never
even you never gave it blowing that no i
never i would never sober i've hooked up
with him
but i was just like i thought it'd be
like a good nice thing to do for his
birthday but it would have been i would
have been ravaged
that's just what we did it's like oh
it's your birthday
that's how little respect we had for
ourselves that's not what
we did annie and i just seen us the
ratchet level was
on kalila did you really do that too
when i was in high school yeah
look at her judgment corner is good it's
not judging i'm just
surprised i'm curious what you said did
you
really and you looked at me like you
dirty [ __ ] of course well you were
you were drunk you were not that was not
you
thank you thank you
started crying like sincerely it wasn't
me
that's our moment from um the notebook
not the notebook but what's his name who
hung himself
who hung himself oh you know the famous
guy wait
um he had parkinson's
robin williams that was his danny that
that you blanked on robin williams
guys i have cluster headaches i don't
know if you realize this i am very ill
right now
so i i woke up with a cluster headache
at 8 a.m
it wakes you up oh yeah it wakes you up
from a dead sleep i hear it's like
feeling like someone like
grabbing your face with um the longest
possible nail
yeah it's really like having like a
screwdriver go through like multiple
parts of your side
yeah it's and it's and then i also get
these zaps of pain too like
these like electrical shocks stirring it
too that are also painful it's really
crazy i'm like twitching
i've heard of brain zaps when they say
when you go off antidepressants you can
get brains
really yeah that's like a real that's
yeah oh that's a real thing that one's a
real thing
the cluster headaches are brought to you
by annie letterman
but i'm trying everything like people
there's things that people say to do
like they snort like cayenne pepper like
there's just like you want to just like
kill this nerve here
they're called suicide headaches no way
yeah people have literally put like
bullets to in they kill themselves
because that's just they want to
put themselves out of the misery but i'm
very lucky because i have the
um episodic so i just get them every two
years for a month
some people get them at every change of
the season some people get them nonstop
oh really stop
is there any research as to what causes
these no it's horizontal
there's a lot of things but they can't
figure it out and it's also such a very
small population of people i think it's
like
under one percent of population and it's
usually guys and it's a lot of people
saying well
yeah i have migraines too oh they're
like are you drinking water and i'm like
what that reminds me when i had
depression and people were like do you
get sunlight
i'm not a plant also look at me
obviously i don't look
comfortable
oh the ashes of the person before me are
cozy
but i am like this is what i am right
now i am like should be pushed around in
wheelchair i'm disabled
you guys growing up you know that cereal
was kind of
ew did you just burp cereal
was the best part of being a kid you
would sit
on the couch and you'd put on your
cartoons your parents would feed you
this
your mom would walk in with a cereal and
then she'd walk in with the refill
to be that spoiled we're allowed to have
cereal on a couch
but then like you get to become an adult
and cereal is filled with sugar
and it's like poisonous and toxic it's
not good for you so usually
i drink protein shakes to get my
protein intake after a workout and i've
been doing this for years but
finally since i've discovered magic
spoon i now have a delicious way to get
my protein before and after workouts
in fact i make my um rice you know rice
krispie treats
with the cereal and there's a lot of fun
recipes oh i have to do that
they're so good i've been making rice
krispies you're yelling yes
no no first of all yes we're talking
about magic spoon which i kid you not in
the matter of one day i had two of my
two of the men in my life dave and
carlos are both like have you tried this
magic spoon
and i was like two of both of them
randomly love it um
you guys magic spoon is blowing up first
of all it's zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs
in each serving only 140 calories a
serving it's keto-friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free low-carb and gmo
free
the variety pack has four flavors cocoa
fruity
frosted and peanut butter okay so fruity
is the one that dave and carlos are
obsessed with um i'm a traditional girl
i'm a frosted just frosted cereal i like
peanut butter cereal
is like where my my i come to life
it tastes exactly like regular cereal
from your childhood but it's super
nutritious
this is like this is a game changer you
guys can go to magicspoon.combathgirls
to grab a variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code
bathgirls at checkout to save five
dollars off your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.combathgirls and use the code
bath girls
to save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
also what is this you were fingered by
your friend so you were
what's going on there she fingered me
well she looked like a boy it was very
confusing
i've never had a sexual hookup with a
female friend ever
no but you wanted to and not even a kid
even look at her hand right now don't
move your hand she's like
she hooked she had fist hand
esther you've never even kissed a girl
i've kissed a girl in high school
i made a sex tape you did yeah everybody
knows that i don't know this
yeah what's a legal child and that was
14. let's pixelate it
no it's illegal uh it was just me and
two other girls
when we met at football
freshman year first football game of my
of freshman year i met these two girls
and we all were like laughing having fun
hit it off right away we're like
and one of us i don't remember which one
was like let's have a sleepover tonight
it was definitely you sleep over by
esther i know
right when we met we're like let's all
so we all have a song our slogan is
sleepover by esther
put them on so i can take them off
and then like we were all hanging out
with so much fun like i literally think
everything i do is to recreate the high
of that night of like
meeting that night have deciding to have
a sleepover even dave has like long hair
is it so from behind do you think it's a
girl i don't
but whatever dude look how defensive the
lesbian's getting i don't
she's whatever dude you i don't look
like a lesbian
boyfriend from behind i mean there's
nothing wrong if i did but i don't
but now i'm like is this podcast like a
like a
tribute to that night so we all we're
like we
we met we had this fun energy we're
having so much fun in my friend's
basement
and then one of them pulled the camera
out and was like kiss
you keep saying one of them and it's
definitely always you but we just made
out and took our shirts off it wasn't
like
how big were your tits at that point not
that big it was really it wasn't like
deeply sexual it was just like
very you know when did your boobs pop
how old were you i don't know you did
you get like were you at the age where
you had teased about it or no
like you know big boob girls are like no
the most trouble no i prayed for boobs
this wonderful sweet girl from my middle
school was the boob girl i feel so bad
i found her on instagram and she's never
shows her like sh they ruined her
really they called her sludge just
because she had big boobs it's like yeah
that's so funny and she was so cool like
there was nothing like
she wasn't like a sl there was nothing
[ __ ] about that is like worshipped i
feel like in the age
range that we're all in now but i just
did you watch kid 90 or whatever no what
is that
moon fry made a she videotaped
everything from her childhood
as a like child star but she videotaped
her
too say hi hello to the camera
oh my god i wish didn't she say like
charlie sheen was like the nicest guy
on the planet he took her virginity yeah
and she kept going like i'm not gonna
say you took my virginity and then she'd
play
charlie sheen on the phone leaving her
messages like hey i'm in town wanna hang
out
wait did you watch it look what do they
show it was really cool it was a cool it
was really sweet too because like
you can tell she's like a really like
sweet sensitive girl and a lot of her
friends end up killing themselves and
because they're just thrown into this
crazy life yeah um and
you can tell she doesn't realize it's
that crazy of a life she's like i'm sure
all kids really and i'm like
i mean i had a crazy life too but i had
to realize you
start to tell people stories when they
look at you and all and they're like
wait
that's what you call an average
childhood that's why i like you because
you're always like yeah and then
my teacher also did i'm like yay we're
all molesteds
but it was actually it was really cool
but she was talking about her breast
reduction because
she got these huge boobs and then
everything was that she got only got
cast as like the girl with big boobs and
everything was about big boobs
i was a little jealous i am jealous too
of that
guy should we take a banana break sure
yeah let's take a banana break i can't
eat bananas i certainly hope on my
birthday episode there's something other
than a banana for me
i know and i get cluster eggs from
bananas
[Music]
you guys it's always either unripe or
just smushed black bananas oh my god
can i have something that's not i can't
have a banana oh you got a tootsie pop
oh babe let's do a double banana why has
she ever not been in a wheelchair
why has she ever not been in one doesn't
she look at home look at her
i'm happy here she's just a little
crouched up
so cute george are there any other
options for my snacks
cherry oh baby food bobby there's so
many holes in your cooled
pants we share we share those pants
what's everybody going to have for
dinner
does bobby bang you while you're wearing
them through the holes he just puts it
out of the peepee hole and that's how he
banged that's so funny
that's like orthodox juice that's what
we do he doesn't take his underwear off
he just puts it to the penis
[Laughter]
we're so nasty i know we do this
game where we spit in each other's faces
oh my god and it's like a bigger louie
each time
oh so funny like chunky we were doing
that when you were watching the woody
allen documentary
that's so funny and that's how you cope
we were just spitting at each other like
he's a good guy he just like to be in
bed with kids
he wanted to marry a daughter we still
have to pee in the diaper
banana we should do it now i think i can
do it oh my god you'll never be able to
panty i have to pretend i'm on a table
wait those panties are so i can do it
wait clara can i see your panties i
don't like her saying panties like it
runs in my
oh my god you cannot do it show me show
me
show me show me now turn to me
take it out it's not coming through
you promised you guys this is the best
birthday ever
thank you for this gift show me the wet
diaper
it's so juicy it feels like a water bed
[Laughter]
okay well it's supposed to be a birthday
episode um
and yes as a joke last summer i bought
diapers and for some reason people
really hung on to that story line and
i said i don't think you'll be able to
pee in the diapers i tried i wasn't able
to
and these two prove me wrong they just
pissed in diapers
and they have their diapers are now full
quite frankly need to be changed hey
guys
have you ever pissed on a diaper while
eating a tootsie pop while eating a
tizzy pop on ketamine
claustrophobics are really bad honestly
i'm glad i have you guys here tonight to
tell you how serious claustrophobics
are she's doing an act they are so bad
like a vlog that's so depressing it's
just me crying
on a camera they really are bad
do not take this joy and happiness as a
sign
that claustrophobics are fake so kalila
how did that feel for you how what was
the change it was really disappointing i
was so disappointed
the absorption was horrible i was it it
didn't absorb so i had to cut the diaper
and put it out this way and then pour it
into the toilet
but yeah that was whatever brand that
was esther you were right the brands do
matter
they of course my friend mm-hmm we
should have stuck to like
depends sponsor us we will product test
the [ __ ] out of your stuff
well not literally just
[Laughter]
we will product piss the [ __ ] we will
product test the piss
out of your stuff um annie so how did
the removal of the diaper
go for you god that dog removal was
smooth
i was sad though that there wasn't um
wet wipes to wipe myself
well it wasn't it it absorbed for you
mine just sat there like a puddle
and so i had to cut it through the sides
and then tip the diaper yeah i absorbed
mine absorbed i think my i pissed i peed
too much yeah
i peed a whole bladder i can't i p yeah
i did pete three times though your
theory is wrong
that was the most the easiest thing i'd
ever honestly i
will find it hard to not be in a diaper
i'm gonna find the rest of my life very
difficult that was
beautiful it's so funny as a kid you're
just walking around like that
i know how do you do it i guess you have
such a little amount of pee when you're
little
that you don't got to be what it is it's
like your arrested development like
you're frozen at the age of
that's why you walk like that plenty to
look forward to because when you get
older trust me it's back to diaper
central or even when you have kids you
become incontinent to a certain degree
oh yeah isn't chris jenner like the
spokesperson for depends no
she is i saw an episode of keeping up
with the kardashians where she was like
should i be
they should do skins diapers
we would be honest that was so fun being
in a diaper
i feel like it's my birthday that was so
thank you esther
that is my favorite part about getting
into the ocean is peeing in my wetsuit
it just warms your whole body that's my
favorite part about getting into the
bath
with someone else oh i've never not peed
on a person in the shower
i will i'll aim it oh jeez
everyone's getting peed on esther since
it is
your debut um
we are going to be
attempting a swing at a pinata and what
corpse did you guys
steal these dresses
i'll take the extra large i'll take the
extra
extra large do you guys believe in
cursed items
yeah sort of yeah sometimes i worry
about that
oh my god i think i just destroyed this
thing
well these dresses suck wait these
dresses are beautiful how dare you annie
they're
pre-loved and pretty like a [ __ ] brown
one i feel like
because i have my period i'm going to
opt out of the dress oh no this is a six
yeah let's not be surprised that esther
would opt out of her own birthday party
little boy you have your period that's
so weird i love my two granddaughters
they just play dress up with grandma's
old gowns
while grandma sits and enjoys the life
in their
eyes my granddaughters are beautiful
okay can i hit esther instead of the
pinata someone who's gonna wheel me over
oh will ya i'm gonna wheel my grandmama
grandmama
happy birthday it's her 97th birthday
i i feel like you are gonna give a 97
year olds attempt at hitting this
esther i want you to really try i'm weak
today
she's on her period she's bleeding out
folks
okay so here we are annie is pushing
esther
it's since she's a birthday girl
esther's going up first annie is pushing
her in a wheelchair they're going about
one mile per hour is the camera on her
okay wait we're not we have to blindfold
her and then make her spin around
oh my god esther will be throwing up
those creams as there isn't day one of
her period so
we are not going to blindfold her as she
is already experiencing some form of
nausea
with your arm in three two one first
strike
oh no
oh no pretend it's carlos three two one
second strike
oh no for time carlos is trying to
charge you for something
for his work
okay that's it you get three strikes
look how happy she was to stop
mommy annie is now wheeling her back to
her desired position
this does feel so good to give her what
she wants yeah i know you guys are so
good you know you're enjoying it
i love making my prince happy my little
prince
okay what's up next take it from grandma
oh daddy blind blindfold oh
yeah she's cheating
that's it jesus christ what the [ __ ] i
didn't even get a swing
[Laughter]
i'll throw it ready one two three
should we tell esther what we wanted to
put in it
there these two maniacs are filled with
rage
oh my god how are you not lesbian
how are we not all dating are we gonna
have three
trouble oh my goodness
this is not what i wanted this to be
filled with i'm a little disappointed
what are we doing this is the most fun
i've ever had in my life is this prom
i think it's a prom pinata podcast
i'll move into jersey if this is
entertainment
will someone assist the birthday girl no
i like when she has to do things on her
own it's so hard for her
should we tell her what we what our
other alts were to be inside it yeah
syringes dirty condoms blood we wanted
to
have blood could there be so many of you
were hitting it and that's a disgusting
thing
yeah because look at your face
when you're rolling back like joy is
very come second to this face
this look how good she is two feet on
one thing
did you pretend like you hurt your hands
too so dave would push you
this is like the funniest day of my life
and i had a headache for eight hours
esther when we do live shows you have to
be in a wheelchair
oh my god it's so when you travel in a
wheelchair somebody's waiting for you
when you land
what's really sad is that this pole
looks like your iv pole
you know we could have cracked one of
these out early during the banana break
you like thoughts i've never had them in
my life [ __ ] ass what do they taste
like
they're like talking to you george you
ruined her birthday she's the worst
birthday ever
chewy gummy ooh that wheelchair is dirty
good oh my god the ashes are smelling
into my skin how did this person die
did you ever know you can die of gout my
dad is serious annie
my mom had gout my mom had the most
white trash disease well that's like
actually not white trash it's a rich
man's disease i know but not anymore
funnel cake is now the culprit what is
it it's like funnel cake
it's like rich foods for my birthday if
there's not a dunk tank and funnel cake
all of you are dead to me and esther on
the dunk tank
that would be so fun for my birthday
it's a special 38.
okay listen i may be on ketamine but
this seems fun are you guys enjoying
this
yeah this is what i'm crying like it's
running out i have been
bedridden stuck in my house crying
and kicking the floor screaming i
literally call my parents on facetime
and they just sit on facetime like cry
and scream
lucky that's your chester's dream i know
i wish
i wish i could give you claustrophobics
for your birthday my dad got found a
bell in the crawl space a bell
were you ding oh no and he said that if
i ding it once
that means feed me twice is white me and
three is an emergency
and i book my plane ticket quick what
would an emergency be for you
out of toilet paper that falls under
white me
what's an ester emergency it's too cold
or too hot
um well this has really exceeded my
expectations
and the candy and you guys pissing your
pants in a diaper
that is a really that's a treat for me
esther i was talking to her yesterday
about my headaches and she was like well
you know
if you want to cut it short i'm like
willing to go to shore
our birthday's a big deal in your life
no i never
i never like to get big with birthdays
because i don't like the expectations
i'm like that with all holidays like
oh today's christmas so it has to be
perfect everyone has to have fun
that expectation has sent me into
depression spirals so
i like to just keep everything low low
expectations
you know maybe you maybe you treat
yourself to maybe a plane goes by while
you're doing your speech
maybe it doesn't maybe a nice meal
a nice phone call with a friend i don't
like to do it big
i like to almost ignore the holidays
every day a nice meal and a phone call
with a friend
it is every day is my birthday do you
blow a cake esther what
on your birthday do you blow a cake blow
a cake i mean is that
[ __ ] okay blow a cake like you blow
candles on top that sit on top of the
cake
that's not a real thing you had to have
said that knowing that we were going to
look at you like this
wait that's not how you say it blow a
cake diaper was one thing below a cake
george what how do you say it
her cake is going to be shaped like when
we get her one no wonder guys like you
so much
well she's always just birthday
promoting the cake
birthday parties were a really big thing
in my life birthdays are so big in my
family
we go all out and it's always it's never
not fun it's always an extravaganza
that's good i invite you this november
to join me for may
we have to wait all the way to november
mine's in july
well november
that's my birthday present thank you so
much i fished my wish finally
esther's deceased for one week you guys
this has been an
absolute joy it's just so fun happiest
of birthdays to our baby slug
i'm so lucky slugs can't move themselves
i'm just so these dots are good man
the stuck in those t that dead tooth huh
the flavors are
i swear it's like fresh fruit i taste
um this is having a fruit salad guys
hold on
this has been truly um a wonderful day
and i'm so grateful to all the bloodbath
listeners i'd be
exceptionally grateful if they'd like
and subscribe this video and comment
something share share it
share it and yeah as always if you guys
post about our show we will repost you
on our instagram which you should follow
at bloodbathgirls
write us a review on itunes while you're
at it if you haven't yet we're trying to
show everybody
that this is the dumbest best [ __ ]
podcast where we laugh in the face of
our traumas
where we roll ourselves around in a
wheelchair with no shame where we make
george do so much work in between the
episodes that it's barely worth his
price we want him to feel terrible with
what he's getting paid
and we are coming extra just rolls in i
cut it i scored some kettle in my nose i
just [ __ ] come in she's at her own
[ __ ] house late
every time i don't know somehow i mean
is there a better situation esther's
birthday's lasted 12 years
and we'll still next week will be her
birthday again we're here
she's a princess and we she deserves to
be treated as one
see annie really does love me i do i
love her so much
i know you want to give all my make all
my wishes come true
the wheelchair is such a dream george
thank you so much
um and you guys i feel like is that it
for our announcements
birthday present she gets to end the
episode i have a tie-dye company
sleepoverbyester.com and my stand-up
should we have some to wear
i will bring some she's how pain she is
so expensive no no i'll give you some
periphery
i'd love to it'd be my honor to share
but the truth is
we'll pro i will wear it i'll promote
you i know you and i i know you well
enough to know you'll never take it off
your body
you have to peel it off my dead body
making it a real treat for me
sleepoverbyester.com
and uh my standup special streaming on
paramount plus and
we all wanna do a joke do a couple jokes
tell him a couple jokes i imagine that's
like a every comic's like
worst nightmare is and you're like oh
i'm a comedian and there's like oh tell
me a couple jokes
it's every comedian's worst nightmare
except there's one who's it's not
i because you just how do you get a dog
to stop pumping your leg
pick it up and suck its dick then never
ask someone that again
and that has been bloodbath bye guys bye
guys thank you so much
write that review
[Music]
my
you